what's going on guys Greg Alva here and
it's John Humphrey in on this side of
the dream that ends yeah well reject
nation this got sent over to us I don't
know if there's an actual trail it's on
the Joe Blow movie trailers so I'm
wondering it's an actual trailer that
makes our actual thing
Archer Kingsman yeah also but Archer met
Kingsman trailer I replied to some Comic
Con video or Nelson it's a feature film
first in franchise eighteen movies have
you seen Archer I've seen me asking if
you see the torture I've seen like the
first three seasons of Archer yeah he's
a funny guy he's got a place in John H
John H John Benjamin h-town Madrid is
alerted I want to get this up I have to
go attend to something personal for the
next couple hours right now it is
important that I tend to this so if I'm
late for anything that drops during
Comic Con it's because I'm tending to
something really specific life happened
wiring come out of happens
they're actually the enemy terrific
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah or like
[Music]
finally some service Jesus how do you
have any jackets without a British god I
look kind of like Twiggy for me doing is
oh that I'm sterling Archer world's
greatest spy
you probably shouldn't tell people your
spy than what's the point in being
damned enough listen I'm legally blind
got it but no I don't want to donate
what the glasses you look like my eighth
grade shop teacher charming listen mate
I'm gonna need you to leave when you get
those oh there's this super cool secret
room you guys hungry Kingsman or not in
there put the guys I'm saying
Louie Louie put the gear back no excuse
me those you blind and deaf I said no oh
I'm done being polite done being polite
are you governor I see say you're
gamblin man mr. Archer well I wrote the
underground here so you tell me well
then care to engage in the most
gentlemanly of competitions druggers oil
or else like what no you [ __ ] a drinking
contest standard Queensbury rules sheesh
man imbibe in a shop ha so this is what
passes for the world's greatest spy in
America one I need to go there and teach
them a lesson but first I'm gonna draw a
knob on your face
what are quite after that what in
Kingsland the golden syrup and the
students used to so many of use it and
with like a son and I long I don't think
that's a real trailer for something but
I hope they could do that one day where
like they can cross over the Kingsmen
world with Archer or just easy as these
like periodic things where they're kind
of bumping into each other's world yeah
makes sense and it just the chemistry
there seemed like that makes sense I
could see that happening between eggsy
and Archer actually going back and forth
with each other I thought it was written
in such a natural way to of how he's
viewing Kingsman and how he discovered
as a holistic or something like it's not
a big deal boy exactly I'm sorry yeah
sorry it's funny because Kingsman 2 is
going to do the thing British my meat
teaming up with American spies but
there's only different kinds of American
spies that are in a Golden Circle
they're not like Archer this promo
crossover thing does make sense look
especially because the Golden Circle is
crossing over the UK with America and
now we get this version the American
pleasure is look like dumbass yeah well
you know we have a certain certain
aesthetic in relation to the rest of the
world never the right to we like to be a
peasant and sounds like to see we like
to blunt and we like to kind of walk
around like we own stuff alright yeah I
think aren't your eggs you can play off
each other in a nice way and they both
you know sort of match on that boyish if
you just you know breaking down the
characters they have that modem Blish
kind of mischievous side but I feel like
Archer probably outweighs echo in that
regard totally totally totally makes
sense for eggsy to be more than straight
man in this situation well that was a
fun video as fun well thanks for sending
out our way you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about and dat John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum house and we are a patreon and a
t-shirt site where us on your body up
the double is Cheshire Box
def shelf bye bye